All right, let's talk about a
single shocking event that
revealed something really
profound about America.
Not just that the country is
divided, but that it might be
operating in two completely
different, totally parallel
realities.
You know, this single act of
violence did so much more than
just end a life.
It was like a lightning strike
that illuminated this deep, deep
fracture in the American
worldview, one that had been
rumbling just under the surface
for a long, long time.
So the source material we're
looking at calls this event the
quake, the assassination of the
prominent conservative voice
Charlie Kirk.
It was a massive shock to the
system for sure.
But, and this is the key, as
dramatic as that event was the
reactions that followed.
Well, that's the real story
here.
And that fracture, it was
immediate.
I mean, instantly on one side
you had social media just
lighting up with celebration,
people saying the world was
safer, some even joking that the
assassin shot the wrong guy.
But on the other side, it was
seen as nothing less than a
martyrdom, a soldier of God
silenced by evil.
See, the country didn't just
split on its opinion, it split
on its fundamental understanding
of what had actually just
happened.
This is where the core metaphor
from our source really comes
into play.
The assassination itself.
That's the quick that initial
violent tremor.
But it's the aftershocks that
truly destabilize everything.
These are the waves of
interpretation, the clashing
languages, and these completely
incompatible worldviews that
came flooding in right after.
And this all points to one big
central idea.
The two sides aren't just
fighting a different battle,
they're fighting on entirely
different battlefields.
And believe it or not, it all
starts with the words they use.
And this is where you can really
see 2 completely separate
operating systems for reality at
work.
For the left, the war is
material.
It's about power structures,
oligarchs, oppression, and
identity.
The assassin a political actor.
But for the right, the war is
spiritual.
The assassin isn't just some
person, they're seen as a vessel
for the enemy.
And yes, they mean Satan.
Literally.
The motive isn't political
struggle, it's cosmic warfare.
So this linguistic chasm creates
our next aftershock.
Let's just dig into a couple of
specific words that carry
immense weight but have
completely different meanings
depending on who's saying them.
OK, take the word martyr.
As you can see here, it means
radically different things.
In its original Christian sense,
a martyr is a witness who
endures being killed.
But in some Islamic or
revolutionary contexts, a martyr
can die while fighting.
It's the same exact word, but
it's describing 3 completely
different ideas of what struggle
and sacrifice even are.
The word sin is another perfect
example.
You have to understand in a
Christian framework, calling
someone a Sinner isn't really
meant to be a personal insult.
It's a technical term.
It's more like a diagnosis of
the universal human condition.
This idea that everyone falls
short, including the person
saying it.
But here's the clash right for
the speaker, saying you are a
Sinner is an invitation.
It means you're human, just like
me, and you need grace.
But for the listener, especially
someone whose core identity is
tied to what's being called a
sin, it lands as a total
rejection of their very being.
One side offers a diagnosis, the
other here's a condemnation.
And you see, even huge
institutions like the Catholic
Church get caught in the same
trap.
They might adopt A more
welcoming, inclusive tone, but
the core rules for full
participation in something like
communion, they often stay the
same.
So to an outsider, it can feel
like a total bait and switch, an
offer of welcome that withholds
real, genuine inclusion.
And now we get to what the
source calls the most jarring
aftershock of all, a complete
180° reversal in how each side
understands the connection
between language and actual
physical violence.
So here's the great inversion.
On one side.
The mantra is words are
violence, that harmful speech is
like a physical blow.
Yet when a real bullet is fired,
it can be celebrated as a form
of justice on the other side.
The logic is totally flipped.
Words aren't violence, they're
just truth.
But a bullet that is injustice,
It's martyrdom.
It's proof their spiritual war
is absolutely real.
And from that spiritual
perspective, this is precisely
why assassination doesn't kill a
movement, it fertilizes it.
I mean, this logic goes way, way
back in Christian history.
Killing the leader only proves
their point and energizes their
followers.
For them, violence isn't a set
back, it's fuel.
This is why the source argues
it's a mistake to see this
movement as just some fragile
cult of personality.
It's more like a hydra, one
that's fueled by a very literal
belief in demonic forces.
So if you chop off 1 head,
others will just emerge, maybe
even stronger than before.
To really get a handle on the
stakes here, the source makes a
really useful comparison to a
more traditional kind of
conflict like the Spanish Civil
War, and the difference is
profound.
Look, in Spain you had two
ideologies, fascists and
communists, fighting a material
war on a single shared
battlefield.
They at least agreed on what the
fight was about.
Today it is completely
different.
One side is fighting a material
war against systems of
oppression.
The other side is fighting a
spiritual war against Satan and
his demons.
They aren't even on the same
field, Which brings us to this
really stark conclusion from the
source material.
We're looking at 2 Americas
locked in a conflict where one
side doesn't even recognize the
battlefield, the weapons, or the
enemy that the other side sees
with perfect clarity.
The ground has fractured, the
aftershocks just keep rippling
outwards, and it all leaves us
with a final and frankly, A
deeply unsettling question to
think about.
What happens when the two sides
of a conflict are fighting
different wars on different
planes of existence entirely?